un trou béant des lucarnes arraché et à
l'intérieur la démolition de tous qui ne
partira pas dans les gravats de la
structure sauver les bâtiments chemetov
semble aujourd'hui bien compromis la
communauté de communes a pourtant voté
il ya quelques jours le rachat du lieu
mais apparemment cela n'a pas suffi son
président s'interroge je n'ai aucune
explication je ne comprends pas
l'empressement de ce qu'alice aussi bien
de scanie sq de que du préfet à faire
démolir ce bâtiment
donc il ya des choses qui m'échappent du
côté de chez ce qu'alice pas d'états
d'âme pour ce bâtiment plus du tout en
prise avec les contraintes énergétique
de l'habitat social
on a proposé la démolition à toutes les
autorités compétentes en la matière que
ce soit le maire que ce soit l'état se
soit l'architecte des bâtiments de
france et ils nous ont donné leur accord
pour démolir ces bâtiments
je n'ai jamais eu de délibération du
conseil communautaire
j'ai eu des rendez vous que le président
de la communauté de communes j'ai
observé beaucoup de tergiversations
depuis trois mois la délibération a été
rédigé
et
hier elles passent au contrôle de
légalité donc une fois passé de contrôle
de légalité nous
environ donc à arcalis les défenseurs de
la sauvegarde des hlm de la grande ouche
argue que le coût de la destruction
300000 euros pourrait servir à
réhabiliter le lieu pour d'autres usages
associatif culturel ou économique